on this episode I talk about what I do
if I started vaynermedia
today I'll talk about the quality of
video and I struggle with talking about
what I don't like about myself
[Music]
this is
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is a 120 on the ask gary vee show
I'm super excited
we've just been sitting here pounding
the pavement on our thousand plus
submissions to join my crew next Friday
I know that we've been mentioning Steve
rightfully said hey we said we were
gonna announce the winners today please
mention that we were gonna pick the
winners we're gonna contact the winners
today we will announce the winners on
tomorrow show episode 121 so that's what
we're gonna do that's the utility part
of the show I have no idea what this
baseball crap is but fine I think so the
intern once you show white space said to
to the vaynernation
I'm excited I'm feeling good I feel like
I've got a good episode in me I'm
feeling happy to be back on the East
Coast I love the West Coast I enjoyed
the talk I gave to in LA I appreciate
all of you that came out for that that
was a lot of fun but I think it is time
to get into the episode is there
anything else we want to talk about I
don't think so nothing really in pop
culture that's got me too excited I
think for you Steve Taylor Nicky's bet
beef is intriguing but not hitting the
radar at the highest levels sorry see
never know that's a good point
India let's get into the show
not bad not bad not bad at all I wanted
to go strive was one stick going
completely straight gives me a
vulnerability of you catching me so
let's get into the show
Cowell asks if you were to serve
vaynermedia today without anyone knowing
who you were how would you find talent
cop first of all I'm gonna answer the
real answer and then the question I
think you're actually answering the real
answer is I would never and this is
going to give a lot of people a lot of
insight I'm always trying to pride value
Sid as you go through your career you
want to provide value so I'm gonna
answer this twice the answer is I would
not start vaynermedia I actually will
never in my career start a business or
be in a business that I
have disproportional leverage from the
beginning to affect the outcome of the
business so the thought of starting a
social media agency where I am NOT a
known entity and I don't have leverage
with brands already vaynermedia started
much like the networking video that said
it was taught by d-roc actually linked
that up the arachnoid skips is like a
sit episode it's a sin explosion guys
let's have a little ding ding ding right
here if you haven't seen it check out
the video I talked about networking and
somewhere in that theme I said let it
come to you have the leverage when I
when I started Vayner I had the leverage
I was already a known entity in this
space at that point probably for about
three or four years two or three years
brands were coming to me I scratched the
itch i reverse-engineered I had a
business because it came to me a talent
came to me because I was known as a
thought leader already in the space to
start a business without leverage either
having the pure talent I'm great at
cooking
you know baking and thus I have a chance
maybe I don't need to be known for my
baking skills but I have this skill or I
have the disproportional known factor
now to answer your question you need to
go out and network ironically if you're
somebody who's inspired by me listen I
see a ton of you 23 year olds starting
your social media agency because it
feels easy right like I'm a kid I know
what vine is you know remember these
businesses need business results so just
cuz you use snapchat to hook up or
whatever you're doing right just cuz you
know how to swipe to the right doesn't
mean you know how to sell cups of coffee
so I think what's really important is do
you have the skills first second you got
to go out and network if you're starting
an agency if you're asking that question
selfishly for yourself to what what
should you do I think you need to go to
meetup.com go to every social media
meetup in your general area go to five
to fifteen conferences big ones around
social media no social media examiner
does a big one in San Diego
like scrounge up the dollars and go
network network network learn learn
learn follow people multiple people
because they're all bringing different
values learn learn learn engage on
Twitter it's the open cocktail party of
the Internet engage with people that are
engaging on comments within my Facebook
posts
become parts of communities leverage
remember jab jab jab right hook don't go
in there and be like hey do you want to
work for me like become part of a
community then leverage the aspects of
being part of that community but it
starts India with becoming a part of the
community like I don't want to glaze
over that I appreciate you're nice but I
want to make sure we really get it here
like you've got to become part of the
community and then you can leverage it
don't tactically because don't fake the
don't go into the reddit community and
your first post is a spam right Steve so
you send you get fleeing to death and I
think a lot of people try to do that and
they think they're clever because
they're patient for a month and acting
like they're part of the people can
sense [ __ ] if your intent was to become
part of the community just to extract
value out of the community people can
sense it Tyler asks in a snapchat
Instagram world is video quality more
essential than in years past
no beat at the rock best question ever
let me go into it I feel like I feel
like I have some depth in this episode
look like at the end of a creative is
subjective and we all like different
things plenty of people 20 years ago
most of our parents even mine for an old
guy told us that rap wasn't music like
can we get over like that reality TV
wasn't entertainment right that YouTube
wasn't real stars I mean this always
happens guys so you know like plenty of
people like content that doesn't have
the perfect mic or the perfect you know
lighting that being said you know a lot
of people made comments that my last
video the networking video was different
than the others who make sense sin did
it instead of the rock like you know and
they didn't say they liked it better or
hated it worse or this was but it's just
different but their doesn't that doesn't
mean that there's one that's right or
wrong clearly there is enormous upside
to great editing and and lighting and
mics you know clearly there's value to
that
but there's also listen Wine Library TV
worked and Steve I looked like a hostage
in Iraq alright India good right I mean
have you seen some of those Andhra I
know you didn't know who I was what are
you started here dick but did you go
look back at some of those look like a
hospital hello everyone and welcome to
the first episode of Wine Library TV
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk director of
operations here at Wine Library and
winelibrary.com
I love that I love it I love it you know
I'm saying one thing I like about
editing you can snap if something
happens Twitter I have a question for
the show recently I've heard hold on I
want to hear hey Gary how's it going
Dylan Selberg here at dill salon Twitter
and I'm a fish show recently I've heard
plenty of social media experts mainly
spurred by Mark Cuban and Evan Spiegel
okay are you ever deleting the history
of their tweets and another past social
media posts because they say that the
context is is out of play 8 to 10 months
in the past I was curious what your
thoughts are on this and if you have a
counterpunch
thanks Gary love you show thanks brother
I don't think I have a counterpunch
I actually agree with both I think first
of all I do think that snapchat is the
closest thing to real life communication
like everything you say to your friends
doesn't get recorded for life I think
that's why snapchat exploded when I
finally made that realization I'm like
wait a minute this is actually the real
way we communicate that's what it
started getting exciting to me that's
why I started in late 2013 mid 2013
starting to get really bullish on it so
you know I am you know Cuban would cyber
to us Evan with snapchat I know where
you're going deal cell you know I think
that uh I think that uh I think that has
a place and I do believe that a
disproportionate amount of the content
deserves to be in a place where it
disappears forever however I think
there's an enormous value as a matter
fact yes sure was one of my favorite
moments in a long time in my career
somebody tweeted sweet red wine is
starting to explode in the US I made
that prediction on a Wine Library TV
episode seven years ago and he linked
towards it it was fun to see a younger
less fit gary taught make a tremendous
prediction about where the wine market
was going and so I think there's content
that I think is anybody here devastated
about the fact that they have these
great pictures or videos or comments
from three four five six years ago know
both the answer is both but it's not an
all-or-nothing and definitely the
Twitter's and Facebook's created this
kind of all for hat forever and I think
the reason snapchats working reasons
that cyberdust has value and is working
is because they play in the into the
yang and this and that and so that's
that I think they both work I think they
both have a place at the table and I
think there's probably you know this is
why beam and meerkat and periscope live
in real-time content has a place at the
table and there's probably some sort of
fourth thing I haven't even thought
about yet then as a place at the table
there's a lot of seats at the tables my
friends and that's where I think people
people get way too all-or-nothing and
they don't realize how many chairs there
really are
thanks India are you are you yeah nice
oh this is incredible yes yes Vincent
asks what's the number one
characteristic that you'd like to pass
down a Misha and Xander and what's the
number one characteristic you hope they
don't get for you great question the
number one characteristic I want my
children to get for me boy there's a lot
because I think I'm really [ __ ]
awesome so if they could be a complete
replication that'd be great sorry Lizzie
I'm just kidding up kidding you know
let's go with first thoughts I think
that uh the first two thoughts that came
to me were and they this may seem
interesting to you depends on how well
you know me number one first thing that
I thought of it's it's sad that this was
first over the second one but maybe
that's an insight that I need to deal
with first one is competitiveness I you
know it makes me sad cuz I know it's
less noble than a lot then the other one
is humility which I know for so many of
you especially this is like the sixth
episode you watch our first you think
it's completely ego but I'm telling you
like I know how much my humility is the
of my success and I have plenty of ego
it's me pulling in those opposite
directions but my competitive nature has
been a very very positive impact on my
life in a lot of ways it's just I
associate that with myself I think my
kids no matter what they do and I don't
mean competitive to like make money
competitive to write the best song of
all time competitive to raise the most
money for this disease of all time
I think being competitive is a very very
lucky attribute and I think that my
family and me specifically take it too
far it can be very unhealthy at times it
causes friction but I would never give
it up I just wouldn't I think it's just
too damn important it gets me through so
much it gets me through so much you know
III want them to be kind I like being
kind I think kind is incredibly
important I think the one thing that I
think that uh that uh you know xx I
really do think I'm a paradox I have yin
and yang to all my own feelings trying
to think about what I don't like about
myself you know god I love myself what
what don't I want them to have this is
how my way you ever want to stump me try
to have me talk negative about my own
self I think look I think there's a ton
of things I do wrong
I think that at times I wish it was a
little more selfish at times I wish I
wish I man my parents did a really good
job I would say the number one thing
that I don't want them to uh to take for
me is I think that I could have done a
much better job in my early years on
work-life balance the the only
resemblance of a regret I have is the
first five to six years of my marriage
with Lizzie I think that I left two
weeks of real quality together time per
year on the table and those are 12 weeks
that I could never get back and then I
really wish I had and luckily I'm Way
young enough to more than make up for
those twelve weeks and so I will and so
I think I
that would probably be it I mean at the
end of the day I just as you can tell my
brain as a computer is not very capable
of like looking at too many of the
negatives then I wouldn't know what to
say do it bring it up you have it but
give me the next one while I'm answering
that will do as a bonus podcast the only
question Oh Caleb yeah like this hey
baby hey my name is Kayla Maddox I'm 13
years old and I just wrote my first book
keys to success for kids get on
amazon.com and my question is if you
were in my shoes what would be the first
step to promoting the book Caleb the
first thing I would do is I would try to
find a thought leader with a very big
audience that had let's say either a
blog or a podcast or a show and I would
try to make a piece of content that
would catch his or his team's attention
so that then that person would promote
it to that enormous Li large audience
that probably has a lot of kids or
younger brother and siblings and you
would get a disproportionate organic
awareness play that you didn't have to
pay for and an instance what you did was
you hacked it by making very compelling
content that would probably be what I
would do you found it
cool all right well that's for the bonus
podcasting that's if you download the
podcast for your Android or your iTunes
device and yes I know many of you and
Facebook and YouTube or mouths to like
leave a complaint like what the hell why
are you yeah we say don't make the
customer do things that they don't want
to do and now I have to go and download
the podcast answer's no fair I don't
like that tough
good show I feel good at some good
there's some good stuff in this episode
said you you really kind of hit the map
on on this episode we're into where is
my let's get into the show t-shirts as
we speak are you five designs well yeah
show me a couple show me a couple
actually yeah let's actually capture my
reaction to them here live I'm sorry and
listen what you know what do you mean Oh
God uh-huh uh-huh should we go into this
one
I like ready go with this one yeah
uh-huh your face is it's not all about
you imagine these people that think it's
all about them question of the day
what's the one trait that you want your
kids to get from you you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
I love that I love that I love that
that's just gonna be the t-shirt she
normally to continue the question here
Steve's your an interesting to this
podcast you don't to look as great as
you normally do I knew this interesting
to drag you into this podcast form I
think this is an interesting question
for you meaning do you view the word ego
less cynically today than you did 24 to
36 months ago by seeing through my eyes
how I contextualize that word that was
some good stuff that you know what that
felt like native pod by the way that was
the first time in the history of podcast
native content that I felt I was doing a
radio show versus for video I think we
might have been you know I have a funny
feeling we're about to get a lot of
social comments of like hey wait a
minuet earth show podcast cuz that felt
like a podcast
[Music]